mein name ist erich zühlke und ich darf
sie ganz herzlich als vorsitzender des
dachverbands der wehr politischen
vereine österreichs
zum inzwischen neunten tag der
wehrpflicht begrüßen
der dachverband weithin bekannt und das
seinem namen plattform wehrhaftes
österreich ist inzwischen der
zusammenschluss von 19 wer politischen
organisationen die gemeinsam
250.000 mitglieder in österreich
repräsentieren
seinerzeit geeint hat uns der einsatz
für die beibehaltung der allgemeinen
wehrpflicht
und nachdem im jahr
2013 am 20 jänner die volksbefragung
unsere ansicht deutlich bestätigt hat
feiern wir seit dem darauffolgenden jahr
jährlich am 20 jänner den tag der
wehrpflicht als manifest des werdens und
an diesem ersten tag der wehrpflicht
haben wir diesen begriff tag der
wehrpflicht per akklamation eingeführt
inzwischen ist er gut etabliert
seit damals haben wir zahlreiche
veranstaltungen hier im festsaal der
industriellenvereinigung durchgeführt
und wir bedanken uns für diese
langjährige gastfreundschaft ganz
herzlich bei der österreichischen
industriellenvereinigung
durch so wie im letzten jahr müssen wir
corona bedingt nur mit einer kleinen
anzahl von gästen hier arbeiten und
strenge corona auflagen erfüllen
doch über den livestream
wenn technische probleme behoben sind
erreichen wir auch eine wesentlich
größere personenanzahl und so dürfen wir
sie sehr geehrte damen und herren an
ihren bildschirmen ganz herzlich zur
heutigen veranstaltung begrüßen dieser
live-stream wird von der harris bild und
film stelle durchgeführt bei der wir uns
ganz herzlich für die unterstützung
bedanken und der live stream gibt uns
auch die möglichkeit
videobotschaften einzuspielen und so
auch eine premiere erstmals in der
geschichte des tages der wehrpflicht
spendet der bundeskanzler der republik
österreich
grußworte an uns im anschluss dann die
frau bundesminister für
landesverteidigung die bereits zum
dritten mal an dieser veranstaltung
mitwirkt wir bedanken uns sehr herzlich
für diese unterstützung für diesen
ausdruck der wertschätzung und mit
diesen beiden grußworten darf ich den
neunten tag der wehrpflicht für eröffnet
erklären
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kameraden einen kameraden es ist
eigentlich unglaublich dass es jetzt
schon neun jahre her ist als sich über
60 prozent der österreicherinnen und
österreicher für die allgemeine
wehrpflicht ausgesprochen haben ich kann
mich noch gut erinnern als ich wenn man
einem freund general wo die friedlinger
gemeinsam veranstaltungen bestritten
habe um für die allgemeine wehrpflicht
zu werben und ja sowohl die jahre davor
als auch dazwischen
war es jahre für das österreichische
bundesheer die auch sehr sehr schwierig
waren
finanzielle ressourcen ausstattung
mangelhaft große herausforderung im
internen system mein höchster respekt
und meine anerkennung für alle die die
mutter bei nicht verloren haben die der
republik weiter bereit waren treu zu
dienen und das halte ich auch für einen
ausweis dafür wie leistungsfähig und
stark trotz schwerer belastungen das
österreichische bundesheer tatsächlich
ist
und auf der einen seite gibt es die die
den soldatinnen oder soldatenberuf
berufsmäßig ausüben und auf der anderen
seite auch die die bereit sind über
das normale hinaus nämlich den eigenen
beruf auch noch als milizsoldaten und
milizsoldaten
dem österreichischen bundesheer und
damit auch der republik zur verfügung zu
stellen und die kombination wird immer
besser
berufssoldatin berufssoldat
milizsoldaten mit soldaten
gemeinsam im einsatz man jetzt
dramatisch gesehen an der österreichisch
ungarischen grenze als das feuer
eröffnet worden ist auf soldaten dem
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz dienen
ich bin froh dass es gelungen ist gerade
auch unter
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
das verteidigungsbudget deutlich
anzuheben
ich weiß es gibt noch luft nach oben
aber es ist aus meiner sicht der
richtige weg und sie hat einen
verbündeten in der bundesregierung der
sie auf diesem weg weiterhin
unterstützen wird ich sage ja auch
klaudia tanner ein großes danke für
ihren einsatz und ihr engagement und
ihre reformbereitschaft im positiven
sinne des österreichischen bundesheers
für die weiterentwicklung für all das
was die sicherheitslage erfordert
liebe kameraden
ich wünsche euch alles alles gute weiß
welche unglaublichen dienste an der
republik leistet weiß wie vielfältig der
beruf der soldatinnen und soldaten ist
und kann euch versichern ich bin und
bleibe nach wie vor auch einer von euch
weiß ich selbst noch mit soldat sein
darf und glaube wir haben das
österreichische bundesheer in seiner
kompetenz für die militärische
landesverteidigung der republik alles
gute und viel soldatenglück weiterhin
ja wir bedanken uns
sehr geehrter bundeskanzler exzellenzen
sehr geehrter herr präsident des
dachverbandes wehrhaftes österreich sehr
geehrter herr generalstabschef
ehrengäste aus der politik soldatinnen
und soldaten des präsents und miliz
standes sehr geehrte damen und herren
wenn in verschiedensten gelegenheiten
habe ich es immer wieder gesagt ohne
wehrpflicht geht es nicht und das haben
wir in den vergangenen beiden jahren
schon allein bei den zahlreichen
assistenzeinsätze und
unterstützungsleistungen zur bekämpfung
der pandemie coop 19 gesehen vorige
woche haben wir in einigen bundesländern
die einsatzkräfte wegen ohne grund
verstärkt in tirol sogar um das doppelte
aktuell sind es österreichweit mehr als
500 soldatinnen soldaten und
zivilbedienstete die zur unterstützung
der gesundheitsbehörden in kuwait 19
einsatz sind
die klassische militärische
landesverteidigung
ist und bleibt das selbstverständnis des
österreichischen bundesheeres das ist
die ureigenste aufgabe unseres heeres
doch darüber hinaus gibt es weitere
herausforderungen für das bundesheer
pandemien gehören wie regionale
konflikte
naturkatastrophen klarer anschläge
cyberattacken und blackouts zu den
bedrohungen und szenarien des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wenn auch die befassung mit mancher
dieser szenarien vorerst nicht zur
hauptaufgabe des bundesheeres gehört so
wird das bundesheer als strategische
reserve der republik österreich auch
hier immer wieder für einsätze zur
bewältigung der jeweiligen krise
herangezogen werden denn das bundesheer
ist durch seinen grundauftrag darauf
ausgerichtet auch dann noch zu
funktionieren um zu helfen wenn sonst
nichts mehr geht
eine weitere herausforderung dieser
jahrzehnte das ist die reguläre
migration jesus österreichische
bundesheer schon seit jahren jahrzehnten
im einsatz
aktuell sind es 1200 soldatinnen und
soldaten an der österreichische grenze
im burgenland in der steiermark kärnten
und in tirol die im
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz migration stehen allein
im vorjahr wurden dazu rund
675.000 der sonnentage geleistet um die
illegale einreise nach österreich zu
verhindern dabei wurden rund 10.000
hilfesuchende fremde und 49 schlepper
aufgegriffen und der polizei übergeben
aber wieder vorfall am montag an der
südburgenländischen grenzen eberhard
gezeigt hat als er mutmaßlicher
schlepper auf die soldaten geschossen
hat dann wird das problem immer
dringlicher und versehen mit einer
unglaublichen kriminellen energie das
sind neue dimensionen und ich bin froh
dass die eingesetzten soldaten beim
schusswechsel unverletzt geblieben sind
aber wir müssen darauf reagieren wir
müssen darauf achten dass die
grundwehrdiener an den grenzen durch
besser ausgebildete milizsoldaten
ersetzt werden und daher begrüße ich
sehr das thema der heutigen
veranstaltung denn die ereignisse an der
europäischen thema der heutigen
europäischen außengrenzen die
beeinflussen die auswirkungen an
österreichischen grenzen und in weiterer
folge dann die einsätze unseres
bundesheeres eines ist dabei klar ohne
die wehrpflicht könnte das bundesheer
all dies nicht leisten die wehrpflicht
ist die basis für alles ohne wehrpflicht
gibt es keine grundwerten ohne
grundwehrdiener gibt es keine
kadersoldaten und keine miliz und daher
sind wir gerade auch dabei durch
maßnahmen auf den verschiedensten ebenen
unser heer wieder attraktiver zu machen
anreize zu schaffen anreize für die
miliz zu schaffen denn wir dürfen auch
nicht vergessen die auslandseinsätze die
werten zu einem großen teil vom
milizsoldaten bestritten aktuell sind
rund 800 soldatinnen und soldaten in 15
missionen eingesetzt
256 davon also knapp 37 prozent stammen
aus der miliz und ich freue mich
wirklich sehr dass das neu eingeführte
angebot mein dienst für österreich mit
seinen verschiedenen prämienmodell als
motivation mit soldat zu werden auch so
gut angenommen wird
wir wollen das bundesheer wieder in die
mitte der gesellschaft führen nur
gemeinsam nur gemeinsam mit anderen
einsatzorganisationen behörden
staatlichen einrichtungen gemeinden ja
und so wie im fall des black ops soll
die vorsorge jedes einzelnen in der
bevölkerung werden sich die bedrohungen
und die szenarien des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts bewältigen lassen ich sage
danke ich sage danke der plattform
wehrpflicht und stellvertretern wären
präsidenten bringer der pulka für das
große engagement für das sicherheits-
und zum schutz der republik österreich
ich bin sicher dass heute viele
interessante aspekte zur sprache kommen
werden und wünsche der veranstaltung
viel erfolg danke schon
jetzt liegen dank frau bundesminister
für diese grußworte und die frau
bundesministerin hat er den bogen zur
aktuellen situation geschlagen zu
ereignissen die vor wenigen tagen
stattgefunden haben denn heute steht als
thema dieses neunten tages der
wehrpflicht migration als waffe im
vordergrund
mit dem einbruch der hungen seinerzeit
nach europa im vierten jahrhundert
setzte die sogenannte völkerwanderung
ein und hat letztlich zum ende des
römischen reichs geführt und man kann
sagen von fremden überrannt und
gebrandschatzt zu werden gehört wohl zu
den urängsten jeder bevölkerung
nach dem kalten krieg
als sich die sicherheitspolitische
architektur in europa grundsätzlich
geändert hat formulierte österreich 2001
in seiner damaligen sicherheits und
verteidigungsdoktrin folgendes und ich
zitiere
an die stelle eines klar erkennbaren
bedrohungs bildes wie in der zeit des
kalten krieges ist eine komplexe
mischung von gefahren und risiken
getreten die ursprünge können im
politischen wirtschaftlichen
militärischen sozialen ökologischen
kulturellen größen und
informationstechnischen bereich liegen
und
in der aktuellen österreichischen
sicherheitsstrategie aus dem jahr 2013
steht ich zitiere wiederum
konventionelle angriffe gegen österreich
sind auf absehbare zeit unwahrscheinlich
geworden umso mehr sind österreich und
die eu von neuen herausforderungen
risiken und bedrohungen betroffen
und dann werden zahlreiche bedrohungen
aufgezählt und darunter befindet sich
auch der begriff illegale migration
weapons of mass migration das ist der
titel eines 20 10 veröffentlichten
politischen nachwuchs der
politikwissenschaftlerin kelly greenhill
und sie spielt mit diesem titel ganz
bewusst mit der analogie des begriffes
weapons of mass destruction also
massenvernichtungswaffen denn durch die
strategische steuerung von
migrationsbewegungen sollen regierungen
laut green hill zu konzessionen bewegt
werden sie spricht von gesteuerter
migration als einer waffe weil sie dazu
verwendet werde staaten schaden
zuzufügen und insbesondere demokratien
die in einem besonderen maße rücksicht
auf die öffentliche meinung nehmen
müssten seien dadurch verwundbarer und
über diesen aspekt wollen wir heute
sprechen
es geht trotz aller aktualität nicht um
die schüsse an der österreichischen
grenze es geht um ein phänomen an der eu
außengrenze mit dem wir uns beschäftigen
müssen also so war es uns mittelbar
betrifft
dazu stand in der bereits angesprochenen
sicherheitsstrategie 2001
die sicherheitslage eines europäischen
staates kann heute nicht mehr isoliert
betrachtet werden
instabilitäten und gefahren in europa
beziehungsweise an der europäischen
peripherie
berühren die sicherheitslage aller
europäischer staaten die neuen
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
und risiken sind nicht im alleingang
sondern nur durch internationale
solidarische zusammenarbeit zu
bewältigen
die sicherheit österreichs und der eu
sind untrennbar miteinander
verbunden
vor diesem hintergrund freue ich mich
sehr dass heute die botschafterin und
der botschafter von drei europäischen
freunden heute hier am podium platz
genommen haben sie werden heute über
aktuelle erfahrungen berichten die sie
seit dem sommer 20 21 als eu grenzländer
mit ihrem nachbarn belarus gemacht haben
bitte begrüßen sie mit mir hier am
podium die botschafterin der republik
polen bioland koslowski
die botschafterin der republik lettland
ja bin ja so wie der botschafter der
republik ito nato schließt hier unter
uns herzlich willkommen und danke dass
sie bereit sind heute hier ihre
erfahrungen mit uns zu teilen
[Applaus]
herr botschafter co schließt mit
beginnen ein bisschen die vorgeschichte
und die ouvertüre zu späteren
ereignissen zu skizzieren dann wird das
so genannte hauptreferat die polnische
perspektive sein und der bezug zur eu
wird dann sehr stark von der
botschafterin aus lettland laminieren
dargestellt in diesem sinne herr
botschafter das wort ist bei ihnen
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich möchte
meine rede mit einem rückblick auf
einige
nicht so alte ereignisse in unserem
nachbarland
belarus becken
zu der zeit als europa und die ganze
welt im jahr 2020 mit den folgen der
chor witt pandemie zu kämpfen hatten
wurde in belarus am 9 august
präsidentschaftswahlen
abgehalten
erinnern wir uns daran dass der am
meisten ernst zu nehmender kandidat
der amtsinhaber selbst war die
prominentesten gegen kandidaten wurden
zuvor durch inhaftierung beseitigt so
zum beispiel sehr hitzigen osten
an seiner stelle trat deine die frau
stadt la nation of ska für die wahl an
die wahlergebnisse haben uns nicht
wirklich überrascht mit 80,1 prozent der
stimmen ist lukaschenko für die sechste
amtszeit gewählt worden
astrid langer zikofsky entfielen
angeblich nur
12 prozent der stimmen er sei darauf
hingewiesen dass die organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
hier mit dem sitz in wien dieser war
nicht als frei und fair anerkannt hat
wie auch die vorherigen band seit
auch die demokratische welt erkennt das
gewählte staatsoberhaupt nicht an und
hält hält es für nicht legitim
nach bekanntgabe der wahlergebnisse die
europäische union sanktionen gegen das
regime verhängt
anschließend brach in belarus eine
protestwelle aus bei der demonstranten
massenweise verhaftet wurden
es gab es tote
vermisste und viele verletzte
nach unseren kenntnissen reicht die zahl
der politischen gefangenen balance
mittlerweile knapp 1000
mehrere oppositionsführer mussten das
land verlassen
zum beispiel svetlana sieg an oskar sie
kam nach litauen
[Musik]
babuschka ging nach polen
einer später im mai 2021
erregt ein bemerkenswert der vorfall die
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit
am sonntag den 23
ändert der ryanair flug athen will muss
kurz vor der russischen grenzen seinen
kurs und wird zur landung in menz
gezwungen
dazu werden zahlreiche widersprüchliche
meldungen verbreitet es hieß im flugzeug
befindet sich sprengstoff
oder
die maschine sei aus sicherheitsgründen
außerplanmäßig gelandet weil jemand von
den fluggästen
mit der grün in konflikt geraten sei
als der flieger mehr als zehn stunden
verspätung in windows landet
da fehlen manche passagieren
zwischen den fehlenden passagieren ist
ein journalist
regimekritiker
ramanovic
es er ist nach der landung in minsk von
spezialkräften verhaftet worden wie auch
seine begleiterin
sofias papier gang ein russischer
staatsbürger bin
wer die anderen passagiere sind die in
der die ihr reiseziel in wildes nicht
erreicht haben und offensichtlich in
linz geblieben sind
wir können nur vermuten
übrigens hat die internationale
zivilluftfahrtorganisation dieser woche
einen bericht
vorgelegt in dem unseres wissens schwere
verstöße im zusammenhang mit der zwangs
landung des flugzeugs in minsk
festgehalten werden
nur drei tage nach diesem vorfall
drohte alexander lukaschenko in eine
öffentliche rede er werte litten und
andere nachbarländer mit migranten und
drogen überschwemmen
kurz nach dieser öffentliche aussprache
lukaschenko schon anfang juli 2021
stieg erheblich die zahl der regulären
migranten die die litauische grenze aus
belarus kommen überquerten
die gesamtzahl die illegalen migranten
mag ihnen gelingt erscheint aber die
zahl der fälle illegale grenzübertritte
hat sich im vergleich zum vorjahr fast
um das
170 fache erhöht
litauen ist mit einem besonders perfiden
form der sie bieten betreuung
konfrontiert durch die
instrumentalisierung von menschen werden
politische ziele verfolgt um eine
anhaltende krise zu schaffen es wird
versucht die europäische union zu
destabilisieren
um die situation zu kontrollieren hatte
dann schnell und entschlossen reagiert
es werden die lutherische streitkräfte
zur grenzsicherung eingesetzt
informationen mit der europäischen
partner ausgetauscht die migrations
bezogenen gesetze geändert und angepasst
die zusammenarbeit mit frontex
ausgeweitet und um internationale
unterstützung gebeten von anfang an
helfe 19 partnerländer schon mit
einfachen mitteln wie betten bettzeug
hygieneartikel möge um möbel und vieles
mehr an dieser stelle möchte ich
österreich meinen aufrichtigen dank
aussprechen das als sei als eines der
ersten länder litten nicht nur
materielle hilfe sondern auch durch die
entsendung des einsatzkommandos cobra
nach litern unterstützt hat
zur gleichen zeit
führt litern gespräche mit dem herkens
länder und beginn verhandlungen mit iran
da der größte anteil der flüchtlinge
irakische staatsangehörige sind
sowohl er als auch die türkei werden
aufgefordert direktflüge nach minsk
auszusetzen
mit unterstützung der europäischen union
werden einige flüge eingestellt
litauen trifft eine entscheidung zum bau
einer physischen barrieren ein
stacheldrahtzaun von 500 und 2
kilometern klang der gesamt grenze von
der zaun sollte noch dieses jahr
fertiggestellt werden
des weiteren wird entschieden illegale
migranten abzuweisen und an die
grenzkontrolle posten umzuleiten dass
nach diesem entscheidung wurden die
grenzübertritt nach litauen und
gleichzeitig nach europa für mehr als
8000 illegale migranten verweigert
zahlreiche offiziellen kommen in den
letzten monaten regelmäßig nach litauen
um sich ein bild der aktuellen lage zu
verschaffen und über die weiteren
maßnahmen zu beraten so auch der
österreichische außenminister alexander
schallenberg und der der damalige
innenminister gall hammer
es sind also mehr als acht monaten
vergangen seit lukas schenkel damit
gedroht hat uns mit illegalen migranten
zu überfluten
seitdem ist viel passiert
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt können wir sagen
dass der hybride angriff gestoppt ist
aber ist es ist noch nicht lange beendet
unseres wissens halten sich in belarus
immer noch mehrere tausend potenzielle
illegalen migranten auf
litauen verhandelt derzeit aktiv mit dem
irak über die rückkehr von migranten
übrigens sind irakischer staatsbürger
breit auf zwei früheren freiwillig aus
litauen in ihre heimat zurückgekehrt
dazu hat unter anderem auch die geringe
anerkennungsquote beigetragen nach
prüfung von mehr als 4000 asylanträgen
ist nur knapp 100 migranten asyl gewährt
worden
dass die lager in der region nach wie
vor angespannt ist zeigt auch der
auftakt der grenzschutz konferenz heute
in will dass die konferenz ästhetisiert
von den innenministern
österreichs griechenlands polens und
litauens
darin nehmen delegationen aus 28 ländern
und auch beamte europäischen
institutionen teil auf der konferenz
soll eu maßnahmen so grenzsicherheit und
migration erörtert und nach wegen zum
zur verbesserung der reaktion auf
potenzielle hybride angriffe und andere
neue herausforderungen gesucht werden
danke
er hat sich dank herr botschafter für
diese ein begleitung und die
vorgeschichte sodann dieses konfliktes
und ich gebe nun das wort an die
botschafter in polen so nannte koslowski
brigadier und liebe kolleginnen kollegen
an dem podium sehr geehrte damen und
herren
mitglieder der plattform wehrpflicht
österreich
zuerst darf ich mich herzlich für die
einladung zum thema migration als waffe
die erfahrungen der über ried polen und
republik litauen und lettland äußerst
wichtigen veranstaltung bedanken
uns allen ist bewusst dass die lage an
der polnischen russischen grenze
zutiefst verstörend ist
das vorgehen des russischen magazins
dass wir seit mehreren monaten
beobachten haben den charakter eines
hybriden krieges die anhaltende
immigration in die europa wird von
belarussischen machthabern unterstützt
deren ziel es ist die lage an der grenze
zu polen und anderen eu-mitgliedsstaaten
wie litauen und lettland zu
destabilisieren
lügen
desinformationen die ausnutzung der
dramatischen lage der menschen die unter
anderen aus der region des nahen ostens
asiens kommen sind nur einige der
elemente des grausamen und zynischen
politischen spiels des belarussischen
diktators
belarus erleichtert die einreise von
personen unter anderem aus dem irak
pakistan jordanien und afghanistan in
seinem gebiet in dem es visafrei
einreisen über flughafen flughäfen in
bella russischen region sehr genau
städte eingeführt hat und ergreift dann
koordinierte maßnahmen um sie massenhaft
in das grenzgebiet zu bringen natürlich
die sogenannten touristenzahlen sehr
viel für die reise das geld landet in
der kasse des regimes in minsk
die dramatische situation dieser
menschen zu diesem zweck zu nutzen ist
äußerst schädlich und völlig
inakzeptabel ich schließe mich daher dem
kommentar der vom damaligen
bundeskanzler scharmbeck an der das
vorgehen lukaschenkos als zynischen
missbrauchs von migranten als waffe
bezeichnet
die polnischen grenzbehörden müssen
jeden tag
massiven versuchen die territoriale
integrität zu verletzten sowie
provokationen seitens der belarussischen
diensten entgegentreten sie sind dabei
mit mehreren schwierigkeiten
konfrontiert sie würden beispielsweise
der anwendung faschistische methoden
beschuldigt beleidigt und mit
gefährlichen lassen und taschenlampen
endet
es wurde mehrmals beobachtet dass
belarussischen sicherheitsbeamten in die
zerstörung der von der britischen armee
errichteten grenzsperren involviert sind
darüber hinaus wurden die
gewalthandlungen gegen polnische
soldaten registriert die an der
verstärkung die grenzsperren beteiligt
waren um zwar sie wurden mit
unterschiedlichen gegenständen beworfen
einschließlich pyrotechnischer stoffe
da die erwähnten elemente fügen sich
besonders gut in die jetzige politik
russlands an ist es nicht ausgeschlossen
dass russland seinen anteil an der der
ganzen situation hat es
mag scheinen dass die situation an der
polnisch russischen grenze ruhige wird
es ist aber nicht so die jüngsten
verfügbaren daten zeigen dass die
letzten tage in grants im grenzbereich
nicht friedlich verliefen die bälle
russischen behörden streben immer noch
das gleiche ziel nämlich die lage an der
grenze zu destabilisieren die angriffe
werden zunehmend aggressiv die polnische
soldaten werden nach wie vor mit steinen
zweigen und anderen gegenständen
beworfen und die grenzsperren werden
zerstört nachts werden durch die
lautsprecher aufnahmen mit frauen und
kinder schreien eingeschaltet um die
polnischen soldaten zu terrorisieren
außerdem wurde uns mitgeteilt dass die
belarussische behörde die lügen über
angebliche verhandlungen über die
öffnung der eu grenzen und humanitäre
korridore verbreiten denn in polen und
die gesamte eu zustimmen sollen diese
zielen darauf ab die migranten zu
weiteren versuchen des grenzübertritts
zu mobilisieren und ihnen falsche
hoffnungen zu machen
angesichts der krise hat die polnische
regierung nicht lange gezögert
und von anfang an
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen ergriffen der
zugang zu grenzgebiet wurde beschränkt
in dem die regierung im letzten herbst
ausnahmezustand verhängt hat dank der
einführung des ausnahmezustandes wurde
die möglichkeit der erfolgreichen
durchführung der operativen maßnahmen in
diesem bereich in hohem maße erhört
außerdem sorgt polen für intensive
präventivmaßnahmen eine verstärkte
präsenz von grenzschützern militär und
polizei sowie den bau einer dauerhaften
spüren was sie auf den bildern sehen da
sind aufnahme von einem
lager provisorischen lage an der
westlichen grenze also deutsch polnische
grenze das beziehungs aus dem polnischen
territorium eine ehemalige kaserne wo es
die wenige die nicht nach deutschland
die grenze passieren würden dort
aufgehalten und da es so genannte
aufstand seiner art rebellion vorbei
wochen entstanden und da sind die
aufnahmen auf diesem auf diesem
aus dieser kaserne aus diese unterkunft
und und das verhalten der menschen dort
an diesem punkt möchte ich klar zum
ausdruck bringen dass polen nicht gegen
flüchtlinge ist in den letzten zwei
jahrzehnten hat wohlen tausenden
tschetschenien asyl gewährt die des
konfliktes oder des krieges im kaukasus
enttarnen im zuge des der
kriegshandlungen in der ukraine hat eine
riesige anzahl vom ukrainer zuflucht
gefunden
derzeit wohnen über mehr als 15
millionen ukrainische bürger in polen
außerdem sollten wir nicht die menschen
aus dem irak oder afghanistan vergessen
die während der anhalt in den konflikten
in ihren heimatländern ebenfalls in
polen willkommen geheißen wurden ich
möchte es noch einmal wiederholen wir
sind nicht gegen flüchtlinge sondern wir
verurteilen nachdrücklich das vorgehen
des lukaschenkos regime indem wir
widerspruch gegen das missbrauch von
migranten als waffe erheben
erwähnenswert ist auch dass mit polnisch
russischen beziehungen früher fast
vorbildlich fahren empfohlen wird eine
große welle russische minderheit und
umgekehrt viele polen leben seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg in bäder los polen hat
eine lange tradition mit den anderen
nationalitäten und völker
boden war früher immer ein völker stadt
gewesen schon seit den vor 100 jahren
vor fast 500 jahren polen und mieter
anbietet denn eine union mit vielen
völker zusammen und bis zum zweiten
weltkrieg
beide länder stehen sich sowohl
sprachlich ich rede mir jetzt polen
belarus als auch kulturell nahe wie die
große zahl weißrussische migranten
insbesondere aus der
opposition zeigt die nach polen fliegen
um der repressionen lukaschenkos zu
entgehen wollen finanziert viele
einrichtungen für die oppositionelle
auch viele vor allem die
institutionen wie zb tv-sender bild ab
das ist keiner seit fast zehn jahre
schon diese unabhängige sender wird auf
belarus natürlich besetzt von den
weißrussischen
russischen journalisten und mitarbeiter
die gerade jetzt ein sehr glücklicher
fall ist in dem sinne dass das die
bevölkerung besser los ein freies medium
aus dem westlichen teil europas hat und
zugang begrenzt manchmal aber doch auch
zu freien
nachrichten hat
die entscheidung der polnischen
regierung war daher nicht leicht zu
treffen sie war aber erforderlich hätte
polen nicht so schnell reagiert werde
die zahl der migranten vielleicht nicht
bei einigen 10.000 sondern beim
hunderttausenden oder sogar millionen
gelegen wird 2015 in österreich der fall
war nicht nur polen sondern auch die
europäische union hat sich der
unterstützung der polnischen grenze und
was wir nicht vergessen sollen der
europäischen außengrenzen angeschlossen
indem sie sanktionen wegen anhaltender
menschenrechtsverletzungen
und instrumentalisierung von
migrantinnen und migranten
verhängt hat
außerdem stellte die erben november 20
21 humanitäre hilfe in höhe von 700.000
euro bereit um schutzbedürftige menschen
die an der grenze zu laos festsitzen zu
unterstützen nach der eu hat auch die
usa sanktionen gegen beteiligte an der
schleusung von migranten nach belarus
verhängt
der anhaltende und eskalieren der
grenzkonflikt zwischen bäder sondern
europäische union ist nicht das erste
mal dass die migration als zwangsmittel
gegen die eu und der oder die nato
eingesetzt die derzeitige umstände
erfordern die aussetzung der politischen
auseinandersetzungen es handelt sich
hier nicht nur um die sicherheit polens
litauens oder lettlands sondern auch um
die sicherheit der gesamten europäischen
gemeinschaft um und um die werte die uns
alle vereinen
die ergriffenen maßnahmen der polnischen
regierung und der europäischen union
stellen ein
entschlossenes eintreten gegen
aggression und den schändlichen einsatz
vom leidenden menschen als menschliche
schutzschilde da
sehr geehrte damen und herren wohl die
derzeitige lage für das ganze europa
angespannt ist wenn sie uns nicht
provozieren lassen
wir möchten sie versichern dass alle
staatlichen behörden auf die
gewährleistung der sicherheit und den
schutz polens konzentriert sind
wir tun alles mögliche und die polnische
grenze sowie die eu außengrenze zu
schützen obwohl die lage an der
polnischen grenze ruhiger zu sein
scheint sollten wir trotzdem wachsam
bleiben da sich die situation in zukunft
wiederholen kann
abschließend lassen sie nicht sehr
gehört der zuhörern an die worte des
polnischen ministerpräsidenten tadeusz
mazowiecki erinnern der hervorhebt dass
wir die volle unterstützung der
europäischen kommission haben die
solidarität mit der europäischen union
und ihren mitgliedstaaten
ist der höchste wert für polen und wir
werden alles tun
dass es so bleibt
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
herzlichen dank für botschafterin für
diese sehr detaillierte darstellung auch
herzlichen dank für die
zurverfügungstellung von beat material
nachdem sich um ein sperrgebiet handelt
und nur wenig nach außen dringt danke
dass wir hier einen eindruck gewinnen
durften ich leite nunmehr über zur
botschafterin lettlands oder jünger und
dafür das wort
guten abend sehr geehrter herr
vorsitzende der ca liebe exzellenz in
der damen und herren als zur letzte
rednerin dieser runde möchte ich mich
bei meinen kollegen anschließen und bei
der organisatorin dieser veranstaltung
ganz herzlich bedanken für diese sehr
chirurgisch präzise entscheidung das
thema der instrumentalisierung der
migranten als den schwerpunkt des diese
der diesjährigen konferenz ausgesucht zu
haben
ich bedanke mich ebenso auch für die
einladung und die gelegenheit auch
unsere lettische erfahrung zu skizzieren
die ist in vielen punkten sehr ähnlich
so
der litauischen und polnischen arbeit
zunächst möchte ich ganz gerne ganz kurz
ihre aufmerksamkeit auf die geografische
lage lettlands lenken also lettland hat
eine östliche grenze mit russland und
eine südöstliche grenze mit weißrussland
vergessen wir bitte nicht russland sie
werden einige minuten später verstehen
warum die grenzen mit russland ist
284 kilometer lang davon festland fast
120 kilometer mit weißrussland
173 kilometer lang davon festland
970 kilometer wie also rest der rest
sind flüsse stauseen und und mode
lettland ist deutlich kleiner als polen
ein wenig kleiner als litauen und es
wurden in lettland 19 millionen
einwohner ähnlich wie polen und liter
und war auch lettland sei sommer letzten
jahres mit der migrations krise
konfrontiert und nicht bitte sie ihre
aufmerksamkeit auf der folie und die
folie zu richten danke hier sehen sie
dynamik an der lettischen grenze im
vergleich zu der an polnische und
litauische grenze während der letzten
monate
aus diesem diagramm können wir zwei
schlussfolgerungen ziehen also die
buchstaben sind klein die blaue daten
sind für polen die orangen für liter und
die graue von lettland also erstens
mehrere monate lang wurde polen mit der
mit abstand größten anzahl der
drittländer konfrontiert im november ist
aber diese anzahl stark gesunken im
dezember hat sich die lage an polnische
und lettischer grenze fast ausgeglichen
und in den letzten wochen ist die anzahl
der lettischen grenzübergangs versuche
höher als bei polen und deutlich höher
als bei litauen und zum zweiten der
druck auf der lettischen grenze ist
mäßig und konstant jetzt beträgt seit
wochen durchschnittlich etwa 40 bis 60
personen pro tag und es gibt kein tag
ohne grenzübergangs versuche was ihr
auch merken swertz finden ist die taktik
wechsel ist der taktik wechsel der
drittländer in unserem fall handelte
sich seit ende des jahres um viele
kleinere gruppen an der ganzen
grenzgänge offensichtlich mit dem ziel
einen konstanten druck keine kontakte
konstante spannung zu halten
die migranten sind besser ausgerüstet
das zuvor sie haben jetzt metall scheren
entsprechende wasser stiefel und so
weiter manche versuchen die grenze auch
aus dem russischen territorium so
überquere deswegen wird auch die
lettische russische grenze stärker
kontrolliert
insgesamt wurden im vergangenen jahr an
der lettischen grenze fast
5000 personen zur um gewesen seitdem
erster jänner
2021 sind ca
590 asylanträge gestellt worden
und es befindet sich derzeit
173 personen in einem flüchtlingszentrum
in lettland um die illegalen grenzgänger
zurückzuweisen arbeitet auch in lettland
der green schutz nicht alleine sondern
mit dem lettischen streit rechten es
gibt in lettland eine berufsarmee und
mit lettischen landes wer die sind
freiwillige die einen teil der truppen
konzentrieren
zusammen mit dem grenzschutz an auch mit
dem staatspolizei
manchmal werden wir gefragt wie unsere
grenzschutz mit den menschen im winter
schnee und kälte umgeht da möchte ich
alles ganz klar stellen es gibt keine
neutrale grenze ohne zwischen lettland
und weißrussland lettland und russland
jede person die sich in der nähe von der
europäischen außengrenzen befindet steht
entweder auf dem europäischen boden oder
auf dem boden des schritt des staates
dementsprechend ist der staat auf dessen
boden eine person steht für diese person
auch zuständig darüber hinaus wird aber
nicht alle drittländer vom grenzübergang
abgehalten diejenigen die krank sind die
ohne weitere hilfe in einem
lebensbedrohlichen zustand geraten
würden familien mit kleinen kindern
werden in deutschland aufgenommen
insgesamt sind mehr als 100 personen aus
humanitären gründen aufgenommen wurden
etwa ein drittel davon kinder diese
personen werden mit essen medikamente
und kleidung besorgt so weit zum
aktuellen bild schon vorbei und zu den
statistiken aber
zum schluss möchte ich erläutern das wie
wir sehen wen haltet das thema sehr sehr
viele facetten
ich kann völlig nachvollziehen wenn sich
jetzt jemand was ich überlegt ein paar
hunderte in lettland mehr als 1000
kilometer entfernt das macht mir doch
nichts aus
tatsache ist aber dass seit august mehr
als 300 migranten unsere
flüchtlingszentrum richtung deutschland
verbracht haben aber nicht nur richtung
deutschland sondern auch richtung
anderen europäischen ländern auch
richtung österreich wenn diese hunderte
oder ein paar tausend migranten nicht
abgehalten wären würden viele tausende
nachfolgen stichwort seecontainer
migration stichwort schenken der raum
von wem wir alle gerne gebrauch machen
wollen der schutz der europäischen
außengrenzen ist unsere pflicht und
unsere priorität die auch dem eu recht
entspricht aus diesem grund arbeiten
auch wir und ich denke wir alle drei
zusammen sehr eng mit den
internationalen partnern die ihren
beitrag leisten mit frontex agentur mit
dem europäischen asyl unterstützungs
büro mit dem
flüchtlingskommissar der vereinten
nationen mit europa mit international
migrations organisation äußerte und
anderen
zweitens kooperation mit den
herkunftsländern und transitländer wie
bereits erwähnt wurde der großteil der
migranten stammt aus aber das ist nicht
alles die gespräche sind mit insgesamt
14 drittländern geführt worden und 20
weitere liegt drittländer werden
beobachtet das ist eine in der tat
gigantische aufgabe nicht nur auf
nationaler ebene
in ausführbare wäre und zum dritten
werde ich im leben sagte dieses
geschehens ein paar monate trennen die
erste überraschungs phase quasi das darf
doch nicht wahr sein von
dem gemeinsamen europäischen verständnis
dass es in der tat um eine neue von
einem drittstaat gut geplante
angriffsart geht es ist keine nächste
migrationswelle richtung europa ganz
klar sondern die hybride bedrohung die
ich hoffnungsvolle menschen zynisch als
waffen einsetzt und sie dadurch
absichtlich lebensrisiken aussetzt
deswegen war und ist noch immer von
höchster bedeutung des baldmöglichst zu
erkennen um diese herausforderung
herausforderung entgegen stehen zu
können
und das hat auch die europäische union
gut gemeistert
mit der von der europäischen kommission
vorgelegten formulierung definiert die
europäische union die
instrumentalisierung von migranten zum
ersten mal und da lese ich vor eine
instrumentalisierung von migranten ist
gegeben wenn ein drittland irreguläre
migrationsströme in die eu entstehen
lässt indem es reisen von personen von
außerhalb der eu an die außengrenzen
aktiv fördert oder erleichtert die
eindeutige absicht des drittland besteht
darin die eu oder einen mitgliedsstaat
zu destabilisieren wenn die art dieser
handlungen wesentliche funktion des
betreffenden staates einschließlich
seiner territorialen unversehrtheit der
aufrechterhaltung der öffentlichen
ordnung oder des schutzes einer seiner
nationalen sicherheit gefährden könnte
zitat ende liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir wissen das verständnis die
einigkeit und die solidarität der
europäischen partner sowohl auf
expertenebene als auch auf höchster
politischer ebene wirklich ganz hoch zu
schätzen und wir bedanken uns dafür
der dreifache aktuelle ansatz direkte
unterstützung an der grenze dialog mit
den herkunftsländer und druck auf das
regime von lukaschenko stichwort
sanktionen hat bereits ergebnisse
gezeigt gleichzeitig mit blick auf die
zukunft müssen wir wachsam bleiben und
wir haben auch noch viel zu tun
kurzfristig gesehen brauchen wir die
lösungen die europäische außengrenze ab
sofort zu stärken langfristig aber geht
es um
den umbau der europäischen
migrations und asylpolitik damit diese
den aktuellen migrations trends
entspricht es liegen bereits die
sprechen den entwürfen der europäischen
kommission darunter auch änderungen zu
migrationsmuseum paket und zum
schengener grenzkodex vor und wir hoffen
natürlich auch auf fortschritt in den
kommenden monaten unter dem
französischen ratsvorsitz hier setze ich
ein punkt oder ein beistrich und stehen
sofort zur verfügung danke
herzlichen dank frau botschafterin für
diesen abschluss der erfahrungsberichte
und sie haben auch den bogen gespannt
hin zu den eu regeln auch letztlich zu
ihren pflichten die sie als eu grenzland
haben nämlich diese diese grenzen zu
sichern und zu schützen und damit öffnet
sich die türe für die inhaltliche
ausgestaltung des folgenden panels das
nunmehr völkerrechtliche und
sicherheitspolitische aspekte
ausleuchten wird zuerst wird reagieren
ohne drk lädt länger über die
völkerrechtlichen aspekte sprechen bei
dettlinger hat ganze generationen
österreichische offiziere im humanitären
völkerrecht ausgebildet aber auch
geprüft
und ist nun wer im ruhestand weiterhin
sind ja lecturer am internationalen
institut für humanitäre recht in san
remo tätig und ein ausgewiesener experte
der uns nunmehr in diese feinheiten
einweisen wird herr privateer sie sind
an bord
sehr geehrter herr vorsitzender
exzellenzen sehr geehrte damen und
herren
migration ist
nichts neues sondern so alt wie die
menschheitsgeschichte
sie wurde immer wieder durch krisen
ausgelöst insbesondere auch durch
bewaffnete konflikte
migration hat aber auch zu krisen
geführt und auch zu bewaffneten
konflikten
dass migration gezielt gesteuert wird um
nachbarstaaten zu destabilisieren ist
uns in den letzten im letzten jahr
insbesondere
bewusst geworden
migration zur steuerung oder gesteuert
die migration zur destabilisierung von
gesellschaften ist damit zur waffe und
zum mittel der kriegsführung geworden
und wenn es als mittel der kriegsführung
angesehen wird so stellt sich die frage
ob
diese gesteuerte migration zur
destabilisierung von gesellschaften
nicht eine verletzung des gewalt
verbotes der
in den in der charta der vereinten
nationen
statuiert ist das gewaltverbot sieht vor
dass staaten
nachbarstaaten und ich zitiere
in ihren internationalen beziehungen
wieder mit gewalt drohen noch gewalt
anwenden oder die
territoriale unversehrtheit oder die
politische unabhängigkeit eines anderen
staates gefährden
die charta der vereinten nationen sieht
auch eine ausnahme zu diesem
gewaltverbot vor und sagt wenn ein staat
mit waffengewalt angegriffen wird so
kann er militärisch reagieren
wir haben hier zwar
migranten die unter umständen
gegenstände als waffen verwenden nur
stellt sich die frage ob das ein angriff
mit waffengewalt ist 1945 als man das
festgelegt hat konnte man sich nur
vorstellen dass ein staat durch
militärische angriffe destabilisiert
wird
in den letzten 20 jahren haben wir
gemerkt da staaten auch gefährdet sind
durch andere formen von angriffen die
nicht mit waffengewalt ausgetragen
werden und man spricht dann von hybrider
kriegsführung diese zeichnet sich aus
das mittel methode anwenden zur
anwendung kommen die unterhalb der
schwelle zum bewaffneten konflikt liegen
es gibt heute eine reihe von
völkerrechtsexperten die m
eine militärischen ansatz auch dann als
möglich als selbstverteidigung
betrachten wenn
nicht militärisch angriff ähnliche
auswirkungen hat wie ein militärischer
angriff
das konnten wir bisher in diesem
zusammenhang mit der migration noch
nicht verstecken aber
es wäre natürlich denkbar dass durch
weitere maßnahmen es zu einer
tatsächlichen
destabilisierung kommt und auch zu
entsprechenden auswirkungen die
vergleichbar sind mit dem militärischen
angriff
wenn man jedoch davon ausgeht dass das
noch keine verletzung des gewaltverbot
ist so wäre aber denkbar dass eine
verletzung der fremde ihre lächelns
dekoration vorliegt die sieht vor dass
staaten sich nicht einmischen in innere
angelegenheiten eines anderen staates
insbesondere in sein politisches
wirtschaftliches soziales und
kulturelles system
das könnte hier sehr wohl vorliegen das
problem mit der freundliche relations
dekoration ist jedoch dass es eine
dekoration der generalversammlung der
vereinten nationen ist die grundsätzlich
nicht verbindlich ist und
keinen sinn sanktionsmechanismus
vorsieht man kann natürlich mit
gegenmaßnahmen und sanktionen reagieren
wir wissen aber dass sanktionen
gegenüber einer repressiven diktatur
wesentlich weniger
wirkungsvoll sind als gegenüber einer
westlichen demokratie
schließlich wäre noch zu überlegen ob
nicht eine verletzung des übereinkommens
der vereinten nationen gegen die
schlepperei dort migranten vorliegt
staaten sind verpflichtet in ihren
nationalen strafrecht systemen
schlepperei zu kanalisieren und dagegen
strafrechtlich vorzugehen
dieses abkommen sieht auch vor dass
übereinkommen getroffen werden
zur rückführung von illegalen migranten
wenn aber der staatschef des
nachbarlandes selbst der schlepper dann
kann man sich vorstellen dass es sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist entsprechende
abkommen zu schließen
das heißt aber nicht dass nicht
starten mit militär gegen illegale
migration vorgehen können
militär hat als hauptaufgabe den schutz
der grenzen gegen militärische angriffe
die hinter anhaltung von migration wird
in erster linie aufgabe von zivilen
behörden
grenzschutzbehörden und so weiter sein
militär kann gemäss den nationalen
verfassungsbestimmungen diese zivilen
behörden unterstützen es kommt dabei
aber
nicht das recht habe überhaupt keine
konflikte zur anwendung sondern
nationales polizeirecht dass
hinsichtlich der gewaltausübung
wesentlich restriktiver ist als das
humanitäre völkerrecht bzw das
kriegsvölkerrecht
und damit komme ich zur rechtsstellung
der migranten die
migranten die für gesteuerte migration
missbraucht werden von einem machthaber
sind gegenstand und oft auch opfer
dieses missbrauchs
und eine reihe von internationalen
abkommen besagt oder legt ganz besonders
wert auf die feststellung dass migranten
auch wenn es sich um eine illegale
migration handelt grundsätzlich nicht
ihre rechte verlieren sie sind träger
von rechten und träger von
menschenrechten und wie bereits gesagt
wurde ab dem moment wo eine person eine
grenze überschreitet und sich im
territorium eines anderen staates
befindet ist diese andere staat auch für
diese person verantwortlich bzw
diese person fällt in seine
gerichtsbarkeit und auch in seine
verwaltungsgerichtsbarkeit diese
besonders anspruch auf ein
ordnungsgemäßes verfahren
und eine kollektive
zurückweisung ohne ordnungsgemäßes
verfahren ist rechtswidrig
in diesem zusammenhang also
sind jene aktionen die man auch als push
back bezeichnet in diesem zusammenhang
ist aber interessant dass die
europäische menschenrechts kommission
erkenntnis gefällt hat im jahr 2020
wo es um zwei personen aus afrikanischen
ländern geht die also ein verfahren
angestrengt haben diese zwei personen
haben gemeinsam mit anderen mit einer
größeren personengruppe
gewaltsam den zorn von marokko in eine
spanische enklave melilla
überwunden und wurden dann von den
spanischen behörden
festgenommen und ohne verfahren
unmittelbar
rückgeführt nach marokko der europäische
menschenrechtsgerichtshof hat dieses
vorgehen der spanischen behörden als
zulässig erachtet und hat das damit
begründet dass das überwinden der grenze
gewaltsam erfolgtes auf rechtswidrige
weise obwohl eine
rechtmäßige möglichkeit zum
grenzübertritt und zur durchführung
eines ordnungsgemässen verfahrens
bestanden hat ob der europäische
menschenrechtsgerichtshof
diese rechtsprechung beibehält oder
revidiert
anpasst
relativiert das werden
erkenntnisse der nächsten zukunft zeigen
zu denen sicher kommen wird meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
die herausforderung für militär und für
polizei die sich an einer insbesondere
eu-außengrenze befinden und dort
illegale migration hintanhalten sollen
diese herausforderung ist sehr komplex
für komplexe herausforderung gibt es nie
einfache lösungen
die methoden und die mittel die militärs
erprobt haben und die sich bewährt haben
beim einsatz gegen eine militärische
angriffe diese methoden werden hier
nicht greifen es wird also darauf
ankommen dass man insbesondere
mittel und methoden entwickelt die
einerseits den rechtlichen menschen
rechtlichen vorgaben entsprechen aber
andererseits auch geeignet sind diese
neue herausforderung erfolgreich zu
bewältigen dann gesehen
herzlichen dank herr durch der ittlinger
für diese sehr ausbalancierte
darstellung der rechtlichen
gegebenheiten und ich darf nun über
leighton zu unserem letzten panel listen
langjährige besucher unserer
veranstaltung kennen ihn bereits er war
schon einmal hier auf dem podium damals
in einer präsenzveranstaltung
brigadier philipp peter ist er leiter
der militärstrategie bundesministerium
für landesverteidigung und er war damals
da um zu sprechen über hybride
bedrohungen und die antwort durch die
umfassenden landesverteidigung
und heute ist wieder da um die frage mit
uns zu behandeln ob diese illegale
gesteuerte migration ein solcher beitrag
zu einer hybriden kriegsführung ist
lieber philippe de fallois
exzellenzen herr präsident wir montieren
herzlichen dank für die einladung auch
herzlich willkommen an die zuschauer im
live stream oder die das ja in den
nächsten jahrhunderten noch nachschauen
können dass wir der ewig gespeichert
beim
als letzter redner hat man immer den
vorteil dass man schon auf das
zurückgreifen kann was vorher gesagt
wurde und dort den nachteil dass man
manchmal das wiederholt was schon gesagt
wurde und das will ich vermeiden dass
sehr viele der sicherheitspolitischen
aspekte und sehr viele dinge die es hier
zu sagen werden wurden von meinem
vorredner erinnern und treten bereits
erwähnt sie möchte so eigentlich in den
wenigen minuten die die mehr zur
verfügung stehen ein wenig einen ganz
weiten bogen spannen nämlich von der
individuellen ebene bis auf die
strategische was meine ich damit es
wurde schon öfter erwähnt das wird zwar
hier zahlen und statistiken unser
ansehen aber wir dürfen nie vergessen
dass wir wenn wir von migration sprechen
und von migranten dass wir von menschen
reden und dass es hinter jeden dieser
menschen ein schicksal steht
das wird dann immer besonders sichtbar
wenn das einzelschicksal in den fokus
gerückt wird und wir erinnern uns an
dieses kleinkind das an einen strand tot
geschwemmt wurde und durch alle medien
ging wir haben jetzt in österreich
wieder den fall eines jungen mädchens
das mit einem schülervisum wieder nach
österreich zurückkehren konnte aus
georgien
diese diese interpretieren machen glaube
ich dann ist ganz klar zeigen uns wie
menschenverachtend und zynisch es ist
menschen für
politische zwecke in dieser form zu
missbrauchen ich glaube das würde ja
auch von meinem vorredner erinnern und
verordnen schon sehr gut zum ausdruck
gebracht ich persönlich
bin insofern auch betroffen weil ich es
auch mehrmals am inn
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz haben da klingt
verstand als junger offizier und es ist
also fast auf den tag genau 30 jahre her
sie sehen daran dass ich mich so gut
daran erinnern kann wie ein schneider in
so ein erlebnis das sich zum ersten mal
einem illegal nach österreich einreisen
wollen dann begegnet bin dem es eine
patrouille eines zuges der in
deutschland auf im burgenland eingesetzt
war
aufgriff
das wasser im jahr 1990 und der junge
mann den wir darauf gegriffen haben war
ein afghane der aus welchen gründen auch
immer anfang der neunzigerjahre sich auf
den weg gemacht hat
den westen zu gelangen oder in den
norden nordwesten aus seiner sicht ich
habe keine ahnung was aus ihm geworden
ist mein mentor das war ein völlig
übermüdeter erschöpfter frustrierter
abgemagerter
traurig aussehen der mensch der sich
seine guten gründe hat der warum er
seine heimat verlassen hat und ich
glaube hier ist das ein wesentlicher
sicherheitspolitischer ansatz
und das ist jetzt nichts neues was ich
sage man müsste sich da man muss sich
natürlich genau ansehen warum verlassen
den menschen überhaupt ihre heimat warum
können sie überhaupt zur waffe unter
anführungszeichen werden und was können
wir dagegen tun dass wir von diesem
phänomen der illegalen massenmigration
so getroffen werden dass sich unsere
gesellschaften und zur länder die
europäische union hier scheinbar spalten
lässt weil das ist schließlich das ziel
des hybriden strategischen angreifers
diese menschen der sich auf den weg
machen fliehen aus ihren heimatländern
weil es dort gibt weil der klimawandel
dazu führt dass sie verhungern oder ihre
familien verhungern
unseren aufgriffen die wir haben
begegnen wir des öfteren
kleinen kindern jungen frauen älteren
menschen es ist ganz unterschiedlich und
offensichtlich sind auch die gründe sehr
unterschiedlich warum sich so
verschiedene menschen hier auf den weg
machen und ich persönlich glaube schon
dass es zu großen teil schon eine sehr
große verzweiflung sein muss um seine
heimat zu verlassen und sehr weit
vorzugehen und ich habe den afghanen den
jungen auch deswegen erwähnt weil er auf
der anderen seite vor allem selbst einen
20 14 diese
menschen aus anderen kulturkreisen in
jene sind die
auch angst machen nämlich denen auf
diese treffen und jetzt komme ich also
zu unserer gesellschaft so zu den
menschen in österreich und ich glaube
dass eine gesellschaft und ein reiches
land wie österreich
ganz unterschiedlich auf migration
eingeht auf der einen seite brauchen wie
migration wenn wir uns also die
demografische situation österreichs
ansehen und wenn wir schauen wie
unser sozialsystem aufgebaut ist dann
wissen wir dass die zeiten wo wir drei
oder vier kinder pro familie hatten und
damit sichergestellt war dass es auch
die älteren von den jüngeren in weiterer
folge haben die pensionen bezahlt
bekommen dass wir somit knapp über einem
kind im schnitt pro familie davon weit
entfernt sind wir brauchen zuwanderung
was wir natürlich wollen ist
maßgeschneiderte zuwanderung dass wir
jene menschen bei uns aufnehmen die bei
uns arbeit finden die ein gewinn für
unsere gesellschaft sind und die uns in
unserem wohlstand auch weiterhelfen was
wir nicht wollen und was also glaube ich
die sorge und die angst in der
bevölkerung schürt sind also menschen
die scheinbar anders sind die sich
schwer tun bei der integration und die
aus vielerlei gründen dann nicht so
aufgenommen werden oder werden wollen
wie wir uns das wünschen
die dann kriminell werden oder sogar
werden müssen und dann entsprechende
probleme in der gesellschaft und im
sozialen zusammenhalt mit sich bringen
und die größte aufgabe der
sicherheitspolitik österreichs in dem
bereich ist es sicher dafür zu sorgen
dass wir auf der einen seite
migration zu lassen wo es erforderlich
ist migration zu lassen dort wo es uns
völkerrechtlich geboten ist das würde
ich auch gerade erwähnt dass das ja auch
eine pflicht ist einem gewissen grad ist
hier humanitär hilfreich zu sein und auf
der anderen seite dafür sorgen dass die
zu uns kommen auch entsprechend
integriert werden können und die die das
nicht wollen
oder nicht integriert werden können dass
also die dann auch wieder unser land im
internet form verlassen müssen und diese
ganz schwierige problematik zeigt uns
warum das ein speicher bildnis und warum
gesellschaften hier auf der einen seite
von einer willkommenskultur sprechen und
auf der anderen seite von einer der
größten bedrohungen die verband zukommen
konnte sprechen
und ich bin mir sehr vorher soldaten
nicht wirklich verantwortlich dafür zu
sein wie strategisch länder oder die
europäische union mit dieser problematik
umgehen weil es das auch wurde gleich
von allen vortragenden ja schon zum
ausdruck gebracht ein äußerst komplexe
und schwierige und problematische
situation ist auf die wir hier treffen
interessanterweise habe ich das gleiche
buch wie unser präsident zur hand
genommen dass ich hätte es gern zur hand
genommen es ist leider vergriffen aber
ich habe so auszüge daraus herunterladen
können das ist dieses buch von der kelle
greenhill dass also der präsident schon
angesprochen hat und möchte hier noch
ein detail aus diesem buch zum besten
geben
diese dame hat also 64 fälle nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg untersucht wo
versucht wurde von staatlicher seite
migration als waffe zu verwenden so 64
mal seit dem zweiten weltkrieg und das
buch wurde seit 2001 veröffentlicht ist
auch schon wieder 20 jahre her
64 x oder 64 fälle werden in dem buch
eingeführt wo starten andere staaten
staatengruppe oder bündnisse quasi
erpressen zu spalten versuchen oder ihre
eigenen strategischen interessen zur
umsetzung bringen wollen indem sie
migration als waffe verwenden und was
mich so sehr verblüfft hat ist das in
einem buch heraus gearbeitet wurde das
in 71 prozent dieser 64 fälle das
erfolgreich war das heißt also das ist
es offensichtlich ein strategischer
ansatz der zu fast drei viertel
möglichkeiten zum erfolg führt ist ein
71 prozent dieser 64 angeführten
beispiele wurden die strategischen ziele
des wenigen der zynisch
menschenverachtend diese
migrationswellen ausgelöst hat diese zum
erfolg geführt was eine sehr bedenkliche
statistik eigentlich aus meiner sicht
ist
nicht umsonst erster sicherte die würde
auch angesprochen
haben wir auch in unserem aktuellen
risikobild des generalstabs das atv
bundesminister letztes jahr entsprechend
verfügt hat
als aktuelle herausforderung für
österreich illegale massenmigration
eingeführt das eine von mehreren
aktuellen herausforderungen und
bedrohungen und risiken und wir müssen
uns das entsprechend nicht darauf
vorbereiten sondern weil ich schon an
meinem beispiel gezeigt habe machen wir
das ja schon seit jahrzehnten so dass
die bundeswehr ist im assistenzeinsatz
mit unterbrechungen aber im wesentlichen
seit jahrzehnten um diese
herausforderung der illegalen migration
zu begegnen und ich habe zehn jahre
nachdem ich an der burgenländischen
grenze stand im jahr 2002 ein anderes
erlebnis gehabt die mich 2002 immer im
auslandseinsatz in afghanistan war und
für mich hat sich damals ein kreis
geschlossen
in dem ich einen beitrag leisten wollte
dass menschen die nach europa fliehen
wollen müssen das nicht mehr tun müssen
weil wir dafür sorgen dass in
afghanistan
solche verhältnisse herrschen dass
die fluchtursachen der menschen
beseitigt werden wir wissen heute und
sehen im jahr 20 23 dass dieser ansatz
zwar ein sehr glücklicher ist aber
gescheitert ist aber trotzdem glaube ich
dass es ein richtiger ansatz ist ich
glaube es ist ein richtiger ansatz in
die herkunftsländer zu gehen in die
regionen zu gehen und da meine ich jetzt
gar nichts was er militärisch sondern
strategisch und versuchen die migrations
ursachen mehrmals hat er schon erwähnt
unterschiedlich sind zu beseitigen
good governance ist ein stichwort dafür
zu sorgen dass und ich glaube jetzt
nicht das der richtige weg ist über
unsere demokratischen verhältnisse
jemanden aufzwingen zu wollen das geht
gar nicht dafür zu sorgen dass menschen
in einer umgebung leben können dass ihre
kinder in einer umgebung aufwachsen
können dass sie es lebenswert findet zu
bleiben und nicht so und lebenswert
finden dass sie ihre heimatländer
entsprechend verlassen müssen und noch
kurz auf das beispiel belarus einzugehen
ich glaube das wird jetzt ausführlich
beleuchtet
glaubt europäische ansatz muss sein dass
wir uns das beispiel nehmen und die
entsprechenden lehren daraus ziehen dass
wir in keiner situation kommen dürfen
dass wir erpressbar werden und
weißrussland ist jetzt ein beispiel wo
die migration als hybride waffe
bezeichnet wird ich erinnere aber auch
an die türkei der auch vor einigen
jahren
man kann es schon glaube ich als
erpressung nennen der europäische union
vor eine situation gebracht hat wo
maßnahmen der europäischen union gesetzt
werden muss denn nicht nur finanzieller
natur sondern auch österreichische
polizisten waren vor nicht allzu langer
zeit in griechenland vor ort nur dort
wird das interessanterweise dann nicht
als hybride angriff bezeichnet also man
muss ein der terminologie glaube ich ein
wenig darauf aufpassen dass man sich ja
so hier nicht von global playern
instrumentalisieren lässt und das bringt
mich zu meinem abschluss wenn man das
ganze nämlich in ein größeres bild
einbettet und jetzt weißrussland nicht
nur seeed oder die das regime das
weißrussische nicht nur so sieht das
hier so ein angriff gegen
wirtschaftssanktionen der europäischen
union gefahren wurde sondern das ganze
eingebettet in den großen wettstreit den
wir erleben zwischen china und den usa
auf der einen seite aber vor allem jetzt
auch aktuell zwischen den usa oder dem
westen und russland auf der anderen
seite dann sehen wir dass es so dass
durchaus ein puzzleteil und puzzle stück
ist von verschiedenen angriffs achsen
von verschiedenen methoden die er so
hier angewandt werden und die
europäische union zu stabilisieren um
uns zu spalten um den besten zu spalten
und du mal so hier entsprechende
strategische zielsetzungen zu verfolgen
vielleicht nicht heute vielleicht nicht
morgen aber strategisch etwas
langfristiges und ich kann nur
appellieren dass wir im sinne der
umfassenden landesverteidigung im sinne
des vorgehens gegen hybride angriffe
hybride bedrohungen wir es erwartet
haben sind sehr wachsam bleiben und
entsprechend vorsorge treffen vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
herzlichen dank bei der trainer und
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren sie
kleines publikum ich glaube ich lade sie
herzlich ein an das gesamte podium einen
herzlichen applaus zu spenden für die
tollen ausbildung
[Applaus]
wir haben nunmehr noch vorgesehen dass
einzelne vertreter der
plattform organisationen stellvertretend
für die vielen menschen die über den
livestream dieser veranstaltung folgen
die eine oder andere frage stellen und
die idee ist dass wir die fragen
hintereinander stellen sammeln und dann
dem podium die gelegenheit geben
entsprechende antworten zu geben in
hinblick auf die fortgeschrittene zeit
bedingung kurze fragen und keine tore
fahrrad wer möchte als erster seine
frage platzieren bitte bringt ihr
langjähriges vorstandsmitglied der
österreichischen offiziersgesellschaft
kommentares logistik schule in ruhe ich
möchte vorweg mich herzlich bedanken bei
den drei exzellenzen sie haben uns einen
sehr tiefen einblick geben in die sorgen
und nöte ihrer ostgrenze aber natürlich
auch unserer gemeinsamen eu außengrenze
ich bedanke mich ebenso beim träger der
hetlinger und beim hamburger theater für
die fach expertise die sie in ihren
bereichen eingebracht haben meine frage
richte sich vor allem an den herrn
privatier da die österreichische
sicherheitspolitik
hat vier strategische linien definiert
und ich habe jetzt bei den vorträgen ein
wenig nachgedacht wie wird diese vier
strategischen linien sozusagen mit
mannstärke und power
bedienen die erste linie die sicherung
der österreichischen staatsgrenze
sind die aktiv mit unter 1000 soldaten
es ist aber dort sei mehr ein
emmentaler käse mit großen löchern weil
wir wissen dass sehr viele illegale
migranten zu zeigen die grenze
überschreiten und es sich dann im
landesinneren stellen wenn sie nicht
überhaupt durch österreich durchgehen
dass die zweite linie wäre die
eu-außengrenze wir haben die drei
vorträge gehört aber wenn ich nachdenke
macht hier das österreichische
bundesheer diesbezüglich sehr wenig
unterstützung gegenüber diesen ländern
die natürlich primär bedroht sind die
dritte und die vierte linie sozusagen
die gegen küste ins personen im
mittelmeer beziehungsweise die tief in
afrika und den nahen osten decken wir
mit missionen räumlich ab aber mit einer
ganz anderen zielsetzung wir sind immer
wir sind im libanon in bosnien und im
kosovo aber all diese vier missionen
dienen ja nicht verhinderung der
illegalen migration
unterbinden nicht im
migrationsströme so haben eine andere
politisch strategische aufgabe die
stabilisierung in diesen vier genannten
ländern beziehungsweise die
ausbildungsmission meine frage daher
präsentieren sie
wird es hier in zukunft vielleicht neue
schwergewichte geben wird es
überlegungen geben dass wir vermehrt
auch um einen beitrag bei der
eu-außengrenze liefern danke
schön bringt ihr jocham die nächste
frage
herr oberstleutnant immer hübsch als
vertreter der vereinigung
österreichischer peacekeeper häufig im
auslandseinsatz und ein guter kinder
front tricks
sehr geschätzte exzellenzen tiere sehr
geehrte damen und herren im live stream
heute bereits zwei mal angesprochen
wurde die die europäische
grenzschutzagentur frontex
de
seit ihrem bestehen eine interessante
entwicklung und stärkung erfahren hat
meine frage sehr geehrte
botschafterinnen und herr botschafter
geht an sie wie schätzen sie diese
agentur ein
insbesondere das mandat und welche
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
würden sie erwarten oder erhoffen
herzlichen dank
dankeschön
bitte macht meistro christian baier als
vertreter des miliz verbandes österreich
sehr geehrte damen und herren
botschafter meine frage an sie die lage
an ihren grenzen haben sie sehr deutlich
gezeigt welchen einfluss hat diese lage
auf die diskussion über ihr wahlsystem
in ihrem land also möglicherweise den
einsatz von reservisten oder
milizsoldaten vielen dank
dankeschön christian baier mayor
christoph goldmann
obmann des arbeitskreis miliz club maria
theresia
meine frage richtet er die auswirkungen
auf die miliz und den
die wehrpflicht in österreich haben wird
die miliz und auch der
komplettdienstleister gas eine rolle
wird er in zukunft spielen
anbetracht der jetzigen szenarien
wird auch jetzt mehr auslandseinsätze an
den grenzen der eu geben aber das
schwergewicht dorthin verlagert werden
und wir jetzt auch schon beurteilt
angibt angesichts der szenarien
maßnahmen in personeller ausbildungs
technischer und materieller hinsicht um
diesen herausforderungen in zukunft auch
damals soll bundesheeres zu begegnen
danke schön herr maria
damit haben wir es doch einige sehr
breite fragen gesammelt und ich wäre
vielleicht einmal als erstes die frage
frontex noch einmal auf nachdem der song
auch unsere gäste aus dem ausland
vielleicht auch am unmittelbarsten
betrifft wer möchte dazu das wort
vielleicht an frontex war frontex die
sie alle hier wissen auch die
online dabei sind hat diesen sitz der
agentur in warschau
wenn ich mit gute dinge 2004 wurde das
im rahmen des lissabon vertrags ins
leben berufen
einstimmig von den mitgliedstaaten und
inzwischen also 2005 das büro in
warschau hat sozusagen wurde eröffnet
und jetzt von damaligen kleinen team ca
30 personen was ich eine gewisse zeit
gelesen habe sind es ungefähr jetzt um
1000 mitarbeiter
natürlich das ist das alles zusammen
aber wir wissen hier in diesem raum und
außerhalb wofür diesen frontex berufen
worden ist und welche aufgaben er hat
aber in angesichts der wirklich der
gefahren und
sich immer vergrößerte
völkerwanderungen aber auch den druck
von der auf die außengrenze auf die
andere uhr natürlich kann die behörde
dass nicht alles überwinden war auch es
wurde auch damals des gelegt dass die
verantwortung für die schutz für den
schutz der grenzen in der obhut der
jeweiligen mitgliedstaaten liegt das
heißt die agentur ist nur es ist wichtig
vielleicht dass diese aufgaben zu
unterstützen zu werden vielleicht
logistisch und
entsprechend
auf diese probleme auf die gefahren zu
reagieren und die wir wissen auch dass
frontex sehr
auch kritisch aus manchen organisationen
die aus
gesehen wird ob das jetzt im mittelmeer
ist oder jetzt eben auf unseren grenzen
aber ich glaube wir brauchen schon doch
ein behörde der mehr einblick hat der
international vernetzt ist dass er seine
art sozusagen auch
gut vernetzt und eine
fachkräfte- und experten besitzt die
sehr schnell reagieren kann also da
können wir uns schon und müssen wir uns
als europäische gemeinschaft das leisten
dass ich das auf die zweite vielleicht
frage als aussicht polen
ihnen beantworten das geht um die
wehrpflicht also der einfluss zu sagen
wir dieses diese jetzt anspannungen auf
die
auf die zivil
also auf miliz in polen überhaupt ob das
jetzt die frage ich glaube in österreich
ist das nicht so vielleicht sogar bei
uns schon
wir haben
nie so lange zeit eine
eine
berufsarmee so wurde damals entschieden
aber jetzt ist die diskussion sehr sehr
lebendig in unserem land ob das wirklich
so lange bleiben so sollen wir doch zu
einem pflicht armee gehen wieder zurück
weil viele polen unabhängig von der
politischen anschauung partei sind jetzt
begreifen wie die welt unsicher ist und
vor allem nicht die welt aber unsere
region und unseres land ganz nah
wirklich auch
gefährdet ist deswegen es entstanden
auch und haben sich wird die sehr
bewahrt jetzt vor allem in diesen diese
krise mit belarus die sogenannte
territoriale einheiten verteidigungs
anhaltende territorial werden sie sogar
japanisch genannt und da sind das ist
eine einheit die die große stütze für
das berufsmilitär bisher ist und hat
sich see bestätigte und in der letzte
nicht nur bei krisen katastrophen klima
und so weit den letzten jahre aber jetzt
gerade an der
grenz krise und zu zahl sage ich nur zum
schluss da sind die diese einheiten
zählen ungefähr um 35 bis etwa
vielleicht 40.000 männer und frauen
europas kann ob es kann die theaterchefs
kann das vielleicht ergänzen also wir
haben etwa insgesamt mit dem berufs arme
um
165.000 jetzt
soldaten dass soldatinnen kann ich das
nur so von polnischer seite hier wir
ihnen das bild so darstellen
herzlichen dank sie haben sich auch
schon gemeldet wollen sie vielleicht
auch dann gleich hinzu hänge ja mach ich
vielen dank
bezüglich frontex also unsere erfahrung
in kooperation mit frontex ist sehr gut
und man mir ich denke alle drei bäder
oder werden betont haben das geschehen
auf unseren grenzen ist ein sehr
restriktives beispiel wie wir reagieren
müssen dass es beim beispiel der
europäischen zusammenarbeit und kein
land kann das alleine meistern und
frontex ist einer der unterstützungs
mechanismen seit juli arbeiten auch
lettische expert lettische experten
zusammen eigentlich zum beispiel in
litauen aber
auch experten aus allen oder anderen
länder arbeiten auch in lettland der
lettische weißrussischen lettische
russischen grenze und eine bemerkung zur
frage von herrn jochen da sind auch
österreichische experten aus frontex auf
der lettische russischen grenze
gearbeitet
also wie gesagt unsere erfahrung er
erfahrung ist sehr gut
kurz gesagt meine meinung nach die
ressourcen und möglichkeiten von frontex
sind noch nicht erschöpft deswegen
vielleicht ich das vielleicht zu früh
über anderen möglichen zuständigkeiten
zu reden denn eigentlich wir müssen
zunächst das wirklich hundertprozentig
nutzen was was wir haben aber noch zwei
bemerkungen zum frontex lettland ist
nicht nur ein empfänger sondern auch ein
geber für für andere länder und das ist
auch für unser sehr wichtig
letztes jahre haben lettische experten
in 14 verschiedenen
verschiedenen frontex operation
teilgenommen
und um zum letzten zu frontex dieser
kooperation die anwesenheit der
ausländischen experten spielte meiner
meinung nach eine wichtige rolle für die
aufrechterhaltung des europäischen was
du sagen zu die die these geistes der
einheimischen in lettland
ist so genannte außerordentliche
situation in drei grenzgebieten und
zweitgrößter stadt daun pius verhängt
seit einigen monaten
und deswegen ist es wichtig für für die
sie kein wort zu sehen die sind ja nicht
alleine auch
andere europäische länder machen mit die
verstehen die lage und das ist auch
wirklich so psychologisch dass das hat
eine gute wirkung
zu zweite frage so wehrpflicht und
migrations krise
frau bundesministerin bei der begrüßung
hat das eigentlich
extra ordentliche situation besondere
situation besondere lösungen benötigen
krise ist so ein erstes beispiel
chronologisch erstes beispiel aber ein
sehr gutes beispiel in der tat denn
wie wir es wissen zum beispiel in
portugal leitet die impfkampagne sehr
erfolgreich ein general eine militär
person
diese migrations krise ist auch so eine
besondere lage und deswegen wir senken
problem damit dass auch die streitkräfte
unseren grenzschutz unterstützen die die
machen mit dass das muss auch so sein
unserer meinung nach aber die
internationale sicherheitslage die immer
labiler und gespannten wird benötigt
auch eine wirklich schnelle effiziente
und hoch
qualifizierte reaktion also sagen
stichwort seiner security
das benötigt wirklich besondere
kenntnisse und deswegen unsere meinung
nach ist das nicht notwendig unser
system wir haben auch so berufsarmee vor
einigen jahren
wir sehen keinen bedarf das system zu
ändern und nach der röhrchen aus also
man kann ein system nicht ändern ohne
das bestehende system kurzfristig zu
schwächeln und wir können uns das nicht
erlauben so zu sagen wir sind ein nato
land da wie sie es wissen man man man
hat ein ziel
zwei dozenten der dik dem
verteidigungssektor zu widmen wir tun
das seit 2008 zehn dieses jahr beträgt
er sogar mehr als zwei prozent wir haben
viele aufgaben bei uns funktioniert es
gut danke
danke schön vor botschafterin herr
butchart
ich möchte nur wirklich ganz kurz über
die frage berufsarmee und grenzen schutz
ist das gehört haben ja im litern haben
hat mehr teilgenommen beide den grenzen
schützen zu helfen das system im litern
mehr hammer eine berufsarmee die hammer
wehrpflicht für neun monate
und was das vielleicht interessant ist
und unterschiedlich von anderen länder
nachdem wehrpflicht du kannst in die
berufung gehen du kannst ins zivilleben
gehen oder du kannst als freiwilliger
bleiben und als freiwilliger in der
armee bleibe das heißt du übst ganz
normales zivilleben aus nur am
wochenende oder feiert dann hilfs armee
aus und eben bei dieser situation bei
der grenzschutz war auch solche
freiwillige
reservisten mal sie dort gewesen
danke schön herr botschafter
verabredete edlinger vielleicht zu
frontex
es geht hier auch um das verhältnis von
text bzw militär grundsätzlich wie sie
es ja so dass frontex zivilbehörden wozu
auch der die grenzkontrolle behörden und
so weiter gehören unterstützen militär
das militär im auslandseinsatz in einen
anderen eu land hängt natürlich immer
auch zusammen mit der nationalen
verfassungslage in dem jeweiligen land
und wie hier auch erwähnt wurde wenn die
nationale verfassungslage probleme hat
überhaupt das militär im inland
einzusetzen dann ist es sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass er militärpersonen
in einem anderen land dort polizei
kräfte unterstützen aber es sind vor
allem polizeikräfte die grenze
überschritten diese frontex unterstützen
können und hier diese gemeinsame aufgabe
die ich genannt habe die außengrenze
nicht den nur gegen militärische
angriffe sondern vor allem auch gegen
diese bedrohungen zu schützen oder die
grenze zu kontrollieren ist eine
gemeinsame eu auftrag eine gemeinsame
aufgabe wo frontex sehr sehr gut
unterstützen kann
herzlichen dank
herr berger-de dort liegen noch einige
fragen auf deinem tisch zu den vier
strategischen linien vor allem und auch
im weiteren sinn zu der frage
ausbildungs anpassung an gegebenenfalls
neue
herausforderungen
vielen dank für die fragen ich beginne
mit diesen vier linien und fangen mit
der linie 1 österreich an
wir sehen und ich glaube das haben jetzt
auch die wortmeldungen der exzellenzen
gezeigt wir sind in österreich da anders
wir sind nämlich insofern anders heißt
dass das bundesheer sehr rasch zum
assistenzeinsatz geholt wird in
verschiedenen szenarien das ist nicht in
jedem land verständlich das hat vorteile
überhaupt keine frage ich glaube auch
dass in krisen wie das geplante mini ist
natürlich das bundesheer da entsprechend
unterstützen soll frage es ist
wesentlich und wichtig aber
es ist eben nicht in jedem land so und
wir müssen schon aufpassen dass wir
nicht unsere kernkompetenz verlieren wir
haben eine sehr kurze grund allerdings
zeit ich glaube ich bin nicht der
einzige in dem raum der sich wünschen
würde dass die miliz viel mehr üben
sollte würde als sie es tut also da
werden im inland für die militärische
landesverteidigung als unsere
kernaufgabe schon einmal sehr große
herausforderungen die wir angehen
sollten und da assistenzeinsatz ist
wichtig die assistenzeinsätze sind
zentral glaube ich sind auch sehr
anerkannt von der bevölkerung aber wir
dürfen den fokus nicht aus den augen
verlieren der fokus ist doch die
militärische landesverteidigung zu der
komme ich dann bei der beantwortung der
letzten frage noch erneut ich glaube
dass die außengrenze betrifft das die
zweite linie ist auch soweit mein
verständnis ist
völkerrechtlich ist es so dass
weil eben armee nicht automatisch in
jedem land so thomas s dance einsatz
gerufen werden können wie es in
österreich ist können wir in österreich
die bundeswehr das verhalten des
bundesheeres zum
kampf gegen illegale migration nicht in
andere eu länder dann die eu-außengrenze
schicken da gibt es andere schiene und
andere behörden dafür ich erinnere nur
daran dass wir auch da ich habe meine
grenzen damit hat denn es muss ja nicht
immer das bundesheer sein dass auch wenn
das wirklich zum dauerzustand wird dann
musste man sich auch rechtlicher sicht
und karl öllinger wir haben überlegen ob
der assistenzeinsatz der eine
vorübergehende unterstützungsleistung
sein sollte in der dauer und den der
vehemenz übungen durchführen ob das auf
dauer die richtige strategische antwort
republik österreich auf illegale
migration ist
was die einsätze bei kann
afrika so das waren der dritte und
vierte linie betrifft libanon so denke
ich dass die ganz wesentlich sind um
migrations ursachen zu bekämpfen also
ich glaube das ist der andere der
wichtiger ansatz am anderen in der kette
nämlich vor ort zu sein nur das militär
alleine ist zu wenig bekannt dass aus
meinen erfahrungen aus afghanistan live
mitgeben und berichten wenn da nicht ein
auch ein gesamtheitlicher
umfassender hybriden ansatz nämlich
positiv gewählt wird wo strategisch alle
möglichkeiten
diplomatisch wirtschaftlich sozial
kulturell unterton dass da gibt es so
viele möglichkeiten wo man in
krisenländern diesen regionen
unterstützen kann und sich immer nur auf
das militär abzustützen das zeigen durch
die erfahrungen der letzten jahrzehnte
im irak in afghanistan ist eindeutig zu
wenig und für zu kurz gegriffen und
scheitert auch jedes mal also da muss
man glaube ich weiter denken das militär
soll eine rolle spielen muss eine rolle
spielen man sich das umfeld zu schaffen
aber dann muss man darüber hinaus noch
zulegen und nation building war mal sehr
moderne ist jetzt wieder etwas an boden
gekommen
also ich glaube in allen vier linien
wesentliche rolle aber ganz wesentlich
und damit leitet über zur letzten frage
ist unser fokus auf die militärische
landesverteidigung weil wenn wir das
können dann können wir auch das andere
und dieses credo davon gehe ich nicht
runter also bis ich meine augen
schließen werde es soll dort werde ich
immer davon überzeugt sein das militär
deswegen auch in einer anderen szenarien
funktioniert weil wir gelernt haben für
den krieg in der krise unter widrigsten
umständen
gemeinsamen zusammenzuarbeiten in einer
klaren hierarchie zu agieren und das
hilft uns auch in den anderen szenarien
dazu müssen wir aber die kernaufgabe
beherrschen diese hybriden bedrohungen
von denen wir auch vor zwei jahren schon
einmal gesprochen haben für mich immer
dazu diese definition der kalidünger
erwähnt hat ein wenig zu hinterfragen
ich glaube nämlich dass am ende von
hybriden eingriffen also das sind 1
angriffe nicht militärischer natur
unterhalb der völkerrechtlich
definierten krieg schwelle das sehr wohl
hier auch konventionelle fähigkeiten zum
einsatz gebracht werden und am ende kann
auch ein konventioneller krieg stehen
ich habe vor zwei jahren das beispiel
anschluss österreich 19 38 gebracht als
typisches beispiel langjähriger hybride
angriffe die dann mit einem einmarsch
aller militärischen geändert haben das
heißt also wir müssen landesverteidigung
neue würde gezogen sondern das ist nicht
mehr neu sondern anders denken als im
kalten krieg ich glaube dass wir die
hier im raum sitzen die sich in der
thematik beschäftigen da auch schon sehr
weit sind natürlich fließt das einende
ausbildung natürlich spielt das eine
große rolle wie wir unsere guten
erziehung und ausbildung des künftigen
kader nachwuchs und das kern der miliz
aber spielt natürlich eine ganz
wesentliche rolle in unserem
meditativen charakter des bundesheeres
sind wir immer noch haben und der
streitkräfte profil unser her dass der
bundesminister letztes jahr verfügt hat
und die ausrichtung des bundesheeres für
die nächsten jahre bestimmt bringt ihr
eindeutig zum ausdruck dass die der
kampf gegen den briten gegner die da
kann der asymmetrie gegen illegale oder
irregulär vorgehende gegner dass das im
fokus und schwergewicht der
weiterentwicklung des bundesheeres zu
stehen hat und darauf konzentrieren wir
uns auch das heißt aber natürlich und da
schließt sich jetzt an dass sie vorhin
gesagt habe üben üben üben sowohl für
die grundwehrdiener für die verbände in
der präsenz als auch in der miliz wir
denken viel zu viel immer wenn wir uns
geld denken beschaffungen auch hier ist
wird daher bundeskanzler gesagt hat luft
nach oben aber wir haben auch sehr viel
luft nach oben in der übungs dichtigkeit
und
ich freue mich schon unsere idee wäre
unser plan wäre dass wir also in wenigen
jahren wieder mal private übungen machen
wo brigaden gemeinsam zum einsatz kommen
und im modernen szenarien gegen hybrid
gegner entsprechend hierzu zu üben und
zur einsatzvorbereitung kommen danke
fürs
herzlichen dank exzellenzen herzlichen
dank meine herrn brega tiere für diese
fragen beantworten und das bringt mich
so denn zum abschluss des heutigen
tages und einer dem versuche einer einer
zusammenfassung wir haben heute das
stichwort migration als waffe illegale
migration angesprochen und wir haben
ausgelotet ob es sich dabei
möglicherweise um eine hybride
kampfführung gegen einzelne länder oder
die eu als ganzes handelt und wenn man
den ausführungen der drei botschafter
gefolgt ist dann hat man für diese
annahme durchaus hinweise gehört mir als
dachverband verstehen uns als größte
lobby für das österreichische bundesheer
wir also daten sind und füllt uns auch
der verfassung und den gesetzen
österreichs verpflichtet und daher sind
die drei verfassungsgrundsätze die sich
mit militärischen beschäftigen für uns
oberstes gebot und
dringendstes anliegen diese drei
grundsätze sind die wehrpflicht das
milizsystem und die umfassende
landesverteidigung und wie wir im
zusammenhang mit einem früheren tag der
wehrpflicht bereits ausgeführt haben ist
die antwort auf komplexe
herausforderungen auch eine breite
antwort und das ist die umfassende
landesverteidigung zu
diesem thema stehen in der aktuell
gültigen österreichischen
sicherheitsstrategie folgende
ausführungen
umfassende sicherheit bedeutet das
äußere und innere sowie zivile und
militärische
sicherheitsaspekte aufs engste verknüpft
sind sie geht über den rahmen der
klassischen sicherheits ressorts hinaus
da werden dann diverse andere
ministerien zitiert integrierte
sicherheit muss auf eine arbeitsteilung
unter den involvierten staatlichen und
nichtstaatlichen akteuren achten
sicherheit ist sozusagen als gesamtpaket
zu verstehen
proaktive sicherheitspolitik heißt
darauf hinzuwirken dass
bedrohungen erst gar nicht entstehen
oder sich zumindest weniger nachteilig
auswirken
solidarische sicherheitspolitik trägt
dem umstand rechnung dass die sicherheit
des neutralen österreichs und der eu
heute weitestgehend miteinander
verbunden sind
in diesem zusammenhang haben wir heute
auch über linien gesprochen und gehört
während beherrschung die sicherheit der
österreichischen bevölkerung
sicherstellen das sind einmal die
österreichischen staatsgrenze aber
natürlich als zweites auch die
eu-außengrenze und weiteres erfordert es
auch ein vor gestaffeltes engagement zum
beispiel am balkan oder in den
herkunftsländern der migration
für die linie unserer staatsgrenze gilt
und ich zitiere wiederum aus der
sicherheitsstrategie die als
entschließung des österreichischen
nationalrats gewissermaßen richtlinie
für das handeln der bundesregierung sein
soll
im sinne dieser sicherheitsstrategie
ist die eigenständige militärische
landesverteidigung
eine unabdingbare voraussetzung für den
schutz der souveränität und integrität
das bedeutet insbesondere die
gewährleistung bzw wiederherstellung der
funktions und überlebensfähigkeit bei
angriffen auf staat gesellschaft und
lebensgrundlagen
aufgrund der möglichkeit überraschender
lage eskalationen ist eine rasche und
flexible kräfte aufbietung
sicherzustellen die fähigkeit für einen
übergang
existenzieller schutz einsätze in einen
eigenständigen militärischen einsatz ist
zu gewährleisten
als grundlage dafür muss das
österreichische bundesheer daher über
ausreichend robuste und durchhaltefähig
kräfte verfügen
etwas später steht eine lage angepasste
aufwuchs fähigkeit ist auf basis der zu
verbessernden fähigkeit zum kampf der
verbundenen waffen sicher zu stellen und
wieder ein paar absätze später luftraum
souveränität und luftraumüberwachung
sowie luftunterstützung müssen
gewährleistet werden
aber es gibt auch aussagen bezüglich des
internationalen beitrages den österreich
zu leisten hat hier lesen wir das
österreichische bundesheer muss die
besonderen fähigkeiten zur
beitragsleistung zur internationalen
friedenssicherung und zur
internationalen stabilisierungs aufgaben
erhalten und weiterentwickeln es soll
auch über robuste fähigkeiten für an
fordernde einsatzszenarien mit
entsprechender durchhaltefähigkeit
verfügen diese können entweder im rahmen
der battle group oder in einem anderen
multinationalen rahmen zum einsatz
gelangen
sehr geehrte damen und herren diese
absichtserklärungen aus der
österreichischen sicherheitsstrategie
könnten gewissermaßen auch aus einem
positionspapier unseres dachverbandes
stammen
denn sie haben einen realen und wie wir
heute gerne sagen evidenzbasierten
hintergrund die ableitungen für
österreich und für das österreichische
bundesheer sind logisch sie sind
verantwortungsvoll und sie sind
alternativlos
dass wir diesen militärischen
schutzschirm nicht zum nulltarif
bekommen das sollte jedem klar sein
unseren freunden aus der geweihte hier
am podium waren denen ist das
unser zentrum sensio dass ein prozent
des bruttoinlandsproduktes für die
verteidigungsausgaben angesichts dieser
großen herausforderungen wohl die
unterkante sein müssten sei aber eher
wieder einmal an den schluss der
veranstaltung gestellt
und damit beende ich den heutigen tag
der wehrpflicht und freue mich auf ein
wiedersehen am zwanzigsten jener 20 23
beim zehnten tag der wehrpflicht einen
schönen abend
[Applaus]